por mayoría de votos más de 5 mil 800
trabajadores de la planta de general
motors en silao guanajuato decidieron
rechazar el actual contrato colectivo de
trabajo y con ello el sindicato miguel
trujillo afiliado a la confederación de
trabajadores de méxico la
deja de tener la titularidad de este
contrato que queda sin efecto y por ello
deja también de tener la representación
sindical es importante señalar que este
ejercicio es la reposición de una
votación de abril pasado en la que hubo
irregularidades y además quejas ante
eeuu en esta ocasión el ejercicio fue
observado por el instituto nacional
electoral y por la organización
internacional del trabajo y va acorde
con las cláusulas del tratado de libre
comercio el tratado méxico-estados
unidos-canadá teme que como así lo
indica para garantizar la democracia
sindical
los empleados conservarán sus
condiciones laborales y sus derechos
adquiridos y ahora estarán en libertad
de asociarse de ponerse de acuerdo para
la firma de un nuevo contrato colectivo
con una organización gremial que tenga
la representación
al menos 30 por ciento de los
trabajadores de esta planta armadora de
autos